good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 35:21 object
class safe special containment
procedures the entire supply of SCP
35:21 is located beneath the site 92 e X
biohazard waste site and is currently
inaccessible foundation waste management
teams are currently working to remove
the biohazard waste and recover SCP 3521
as well as any other items that can be
recovered from the site 92 wee X
location description SCP 3521 is the
group designation for a supply of 16
pharmaceutical gel tablets created by an
individual called Nadeau and collected
messages currently believed to be an
amateur para pharmacologist in
affiliation with an unknown assassin SCP
3521 instances are light yellow in color
and roughly 1.2 centimetres in length
SCP 3521 dissolve quickly in water and
are made up of an unknown and likely
anomalous series of components the
primary anomalous nature of SCP 35:21 is
only revealed once SCP 35:21 has been
ingested by a subject
shortly after consumption an extremely
large number of unpeeled bananas will
begin to manifest in the subject stomach
at an indeterminate rate based on
information recovered during the
discovery of SCP 35:21 it is believed
this volume of bananas is intended to
cause an acute lethal dose of ionizing
radiation while bananas do contain trace
amounts of radioactive potassium the
quantity manifested induces the much
more obvious causes
of death of exsanguination suffocation
or in most confirmed cases of SCP 35:21
gross crushed trauma from 9.15 million
kilograms of bananas manifesting within
the subjects stomach
addendum 35 21.1 discovery and testing
the collective supply of SCP 3521 was
discovered after a shootout between the
Atlanta Police Department and an unknown
group of individuals believed to be
connected to a heroin manufacturing ring
during investigation of the storehouse
the individuals had been guarding a bag
containing every known instance of
scp-352 21 was discovered along with a
recently registered cell phone commonly
referred to as a burner phone the
contents of messages contained on this
cell phone are available in addendum 35
21 point to a full investigation of the
storehouse yielded several additional
anomalous items which were recovered by
foundation personnel along with
instances of scp-1370 2d 28:49 one was
chosen for testing the effects of SCP
35:21 d 2849 one was given a dose of SCP
35:21 and placed under observation based
on recovered video footage after roughly
30 minutes d 2849 one briefly complained
about an intense stomach pain before
expanding rapidly and disappearing under
a quickly growing mass of bananas the
testing chamber was consumed in seconds
and a significant portion of the site's
lower levels were destroyed in minutes
rescue efforts began almost immediately
as a significant number of staff members
were trapped below the surface in areas
now inaccessible due to the expanse of
bananas further hindering rescue efforts
was the fact the massive bananas which
quickly collapsed under pressure from
the earth around them into a thick
slurry was extremely radioactive
due to this the first external notice
that site 92 had experienced a critical
event was when site 17 received a
radiation warning notification usually
the result of a reactor failure site 92
was evacuated though 23 members of site
research staff and 61 other personnel
were killed in the aftermath of the
event due to the volume of radioactive
biological waste beneath site 92 every
accessible anomalous object was moved to
nearby sites and the site was
decommissioned recovery efforts are
ongoing
addendum 35:21 2 recovered cellphone
data which obviously but I need
something from you what are you looking
for when I work with oh we usually come
with you to William well polonium what
plutonium - easy to trace here need to
be discreet
no lutonium what do you have in mind
but there am i was the dancing him any
more discrete ammonium easy to hide
we'll use banana but that is a
radioactive is how many bananas we need
you let me worry about that day when you
need it in Palestine I know you're
supposed to be some kind of savant but I
don't know about this are you sure that
really 100 bananas are more discrete the
plutonium because I feel like they
aren't you filming you see plutonium
around and you see banana which you're
worried about I get that but that could
be a lot of bananas right but this one
really really like the one you'll need
to learn to trust this potato just
effective Estonia plus you can't treat
it
get pointed at the Rosalie's okay okay I
just wasn't sure
canna for the [ __ ] up again usually the
Lord will guide good you trust a doe and
everything be okay
nobody banana even better than plutonium
you know that's one thing I love about
these anomalous para pharmacologist
style people they couldn't just make an
anomalous cure for cancer no no no let's
not cure cancer let's make a banana pill
I wish I was as smart as this date oh I
would cure cancer like that that was a
rant and was not professional I
apologize for that anyway I think that
definitely about does it today thank you
all for listening if indeed you still
are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
hello everyone so if you like this video
now you thought I was gonna say it like
and subscribe know if you liked this
rating I think you'll really like the
live-action adaptation of the phone call
between the assassin and a doe so
instead of me introducing it I'm gonna
let James from forlorn find REE
introduce it for me so here you go hey
guys Roland found you here we made a
live-action adaption of SCP 3521 it's a
blast we make live-action espy shorts
every month so be sure to check us out
links to that video will be in the video
description or the an screen to this
video if I can get it working while
you're over there check out some of
their other videos they're really well
made they're both really talented
filmmakers and they work so hard so send
them some love and that's everything
thanks for listening and I hope you
enjoy their video as well as mine
hopefully you enjoyed mine too
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert GM's
Sabah Kareem L afternoon we Justin day
Thomas Morin Curie kuma and jayvo Jack
crystal spice goddess of Donuts my
archive curator Nick Joseph Lewis ooh
agent vamp King modding the wanderer and
dr. Proctor thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the vulgar
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]